do you think you're a perfectionist well
it's pretty likely perfectionism has
been on the rise since the 1980s
especially amongst young people and it
turns out perfectionism is actually a
bit of a spectrum perfectionism is not
black or white it's not I am a
perfectionist or you aren't a
perfectionist but it's really where we
sit on the perfectionism spectrum and
some of us will be more perfectionistic
on that Spectrum some will be a little
less most will be in the middle and the
big contribution I think of my work and
also I've updated this data for the book
is showing that that middle bit of the
Perfection Spectrum where most of us sit
is slowly creeping upwards and we're
seeing growing levels of perfectionism
over time particularly among young
people